feeling good yes my daughter Mia she
they said they'll cardi B getting candid
about her post-baby body can we talk
about your abs by the way getting that
Instagram post yeah girl what are you
doing stuff stuff
you look amazing but you're always open
about your body and your post baby body
but I've been very depressed because I
cannot stop losing weight how are you
feeling right now I feel good and then
some sounds that feel like now you know
what I'm saying like your skin is it's
like more stretched ow
I just got my boobs redone did you
really yes
are you in pain at all uh no no no no
more and my daughter Mia she did but
nothing in this world I like more the
culture how do you deal with balancing
everything because your career just gets
bigger and bigger and your star just
grows and grows
are you experiencing that moms guilt a
little bit I do experience that mom
guilt you know like is that right now my
baby's with me oh she's here yeah she's
here but it like it makes me so sad
sometimes because it's like oh my gosh
all that traveling I know her sleeping
schedule is getting a little messed up
and I know every single time that she
get on an airplane it's all good until
the landing she starts crying and I just
be feeling so sad because it's like I
know the pain you know where your ears
pop mm-hmm
I just be so sad and like sometimes I
wake up in the morning and I she's in my
bed and I just want to cuddle and it
getting harder for you it is getting
harder because she knows me like you
know she recognizes more now and it's
just like you could just tell that she
like wants me there like sometimes we
should see we leave me she looking at
this way boy but don't expect to hear
culture following in her musical Mama's
footsteps any time soon are we gonna
hear culture on the upcoming album dj
khaled did that Beyonce's done that I
don't know I don't know I just get too
emotional income okay like I did a baby
song they are supposed to be on my first
album and it's a good
they when I hear it I say you cry-baby
though
maybe maybe cardi big rhinos offsets and
things are all good for her and husband
offset
I love the clout video you an offset
looked amazing how are you guys doing
really good yeah good things depending a
lot of good things yeah
yes are you still thinking about more
kids yes yeah you've done songs together
before what does that dynamic like when
you guys are on set it was actually
really easy was the crazy thing is that
is like us I had such a bad migraine
that day it was so terrible and as soon
as I finish the music video he just got
me in a car and rushed me to a hospital
wait that's so sweet no and you're okay
though obviously not yes it's just my
crazy stuff EG got olive cardis life
updates exclusively on the set of her
fashion Nova campaign like I wanted like
a neon jungles no something different
like you know I I know a lot of people
like expect like my collection to be
like all girls in a white screen and
just showing the outfits no I really
want like to look like a really high
fashion campaign because you know I'm
saying we're doing high fashion on an
affordable budget
[Music]